here on FYI we feel people our age
should get a sale on the issues that
affect us even if we don't get to vote
in elections so we asked the prime
minister to come an FYI and take
questions from you and us and he said
yes coming up in this interview we get
his reaction to the issues that are
important to us
so I am committed to making sure that we
leave our environment in a much better
state for you guys from underage vaping
there are adverts for these things are
designed to appeal to kids that's not
right that flavors this is all things
that shouldn't be happening our
education doesn't mean everyone has to
do maths a level but what it does mean
is we need to study some maths up to 18.
but surely we can just use our phones
why is it that we have to know it in our
heads and his relationship with the King
you know when I have these conversations
with him and I can see just how
unbelievably committed he is to serving
our country
so what do we know about the UK's 57th
prime minister
well he's a very successful businessman
he's richer than the king
he's married and has two children
Krishna age 12 and Anushka age 10.
and at 42 he is younger than every PM
before him except William Pitt the
younger he was just 24.
Rishi sunak is also the UK's first Hindu
prime minister
[Music]
prime minister thank you so much for
coming on FYI well Maya it's great to be
with you Brandon great to be with you
too thanks for having me yeah so thank
you so much for joining us now the thing
is you know food and energy Still
Remains super expensive lots of families
are really struggling for money and
workers are still striking overpay how
is it going for you say the most
important thing that I'm working on at
the moment is easing the cost of living
for everybody the energy companies are
making a lot of money because of the war
that's happening in Ukraine we didn't
think that was right so what we've done
is we're taxing those energy companies
more we're using that money to help pay
everyone so that's worth about 1 500
pounds discount on their energy bill as
a result of that so that's what we're
doing to help with energy costs and for
the most vulnerable families those who
really need extra help we're putting
lots and lots of extra money to help
them over the course of this year but
I'm confident over the course of this
year we're going to ease these pressures
and it's going to feel a lot better for
everyone so prime minister members of
our FYI News Club from schools across
the country have been sending in their
questions and this one's from Ruby
it's been a hard winter for us all but
how do you know how to help struggling
families when you are so rich
so what I'd say to Ruby is the best way
to judge people is not by what job
they're doing or where they come from
right it's about what they're actually
doing and I think you can judge me by my
actions you know you're going to meet
lots of different people in your lives
they're all going to come from lots of
different places they're going to look
different they're going to sound
different they're going to live in
different places can have lots of
different things that their parents did
and we shouldn't judge them we shouldn't
judge anybody on any you guys know that
recently an FYI investigation revealed a
rising number of children a vaping and
that these electric cigarettes which
contain addictive nicotine can be
damaging to our health
we heard from kids who were sold Vapes
illegally by shops
how do you get hold of The Vape products
so there are some shops that do sell to
under 18s and I get them off quite a lot
of my friends like my friends they'll be
doing it in school and the toilets and
stuff like that and they can't go a day
without doing it
vaping companies aren't allowed to
Target teenagers with advertising for
e-cigarettes
and we discovered loads of products that
had names flavors and colors that
children would find appealing
we're gonna send this program to the
prime minister so he can see what we
found out now he's seen our
investigation the Prime Minister wanted
to give his reaction
in our interview he accuses vaping
companies of deliberately targeting
children with their products so Brent
first of all well done on your
documentary thank you because right this
is a great example of having your voice
heard here you go right you've put this
agenda right everyone watching should be
like that's pretty impressive right
investigative journalism here you go and
actually if you look today at some
newspapers they've done their reports as
well you know they're catching up with
you you know look I you know no one
should be vaping under 18. it's illegal
to sell Vapes to to Children the adverts
for these things are designed to appeal
to kids you know with the colors they
use the characters they use that's not
right the flavors this is all things
that shouldn't be happening now Health
experts are saying that your idea of a
Crackdown Squad does very little to stop
underage vaping and they say if we do
want to stop this issue then we have to
ban any vaping product with bright
colors and sweet flavors so what are we
going to do so we're doing a couple of
things one is we are having a Crackdown
Squad we put millions of pounds behind
it and they're going to go and make sure
all the rules are in enforced and people
should not be selling vaping products to
young people and if they do then bad
things will happen to them but also
we've got this thing called a call for
evidence where we're asking people what
do you think the best ideas are for us
to crack down on this thing and that's
how governments make policy I don't just
wake up in the morning and just announce
something you know we take the time to
talk to people to listen to get ideas
and then make the right decision and
those are some ideas that I hope people
will feed in to this process and then we
can look at those and look at all the
other ideas and then figure out what's
the right one to do and if we do that
maybe you and I can have a chat about it
when we do it Rishi sunak was voted into
power through a contest held by his
political party the conservatives that's
because the previous prime minister Liz
truss was forced to resign because she
made some bad decisions that made
families financially worse off and she
had replaced Boris Johnson who was also
forced to quit when more than 50 people
from his own party resign and protest
over his leadership I want to thank
everybody here and
hasta la vista baby thank you this is
another question from our FYI News Club
[Music]
what makes you different to aside from
the two other Prime Ministers who were
forced to resign
well again I I just you know not compare
myself to other people I'd say to
everybody just look at what I'm doing
but the most important thing is look I
have two young kids as well I want to
make sure that when I'm done with this
job that I've I've made sure that their
future your future all our children's
future is going to look really great so
whether it's making sure that the
environment's in good shape that your
schools are amazing that you've got
great jobs to go to that your parents
have you know got that little bit of
extra cash to go on a nice holiday and
all those things those are all the
things I'm trying to do
Mr invited FYI to London screen Academy
for our exclusive interview he'd come to
this college to make a big announcement
about our education more maths up until
we're 18. without a solid foundation in
maths our children risk being left
behind we say things like oh maths I
can't do that it's not for me and
everyone laughs but we never make a joke
like that about not being able to read
so we've got to change this anti-maths
mindset now what about the focus on
maths and that we all have to study it
until we're 18 years old yeah I mean a
lot of us leave school with poor reading
skills for example and other subjects
like music are being reduced aren't we a
country famous for our creative industry
where are we sitting we're sitting at a
place called The London screen Academy
which is one of the Premier schools
sixth form colleges in London training
people to go into that industry and you
know what they've put on the curriculum
here maths and you know what the biggest
skill shortage is in the movie and TV
industry technical skills and that's why
mass is so important it's important for
every career and if you think about all
the different people who go into
producing a movie or a TV program they
need maths if you're designing a set you
need to understand geometry if you're
putting together the budget for a you
know an advert or a music video you need
to understand basic accounting Canada
France Germany Australia Japan Norway
Finland America all of them study math
up to 18 and what I don't want is for
you guys to be left behind
we asked FYI news clubs what they think
people should have Choice whether they
want to keep on learning maths because
children might choose a different career
path and people don't always necessarily
like maths I think um learning math in
2018 is a good idea because if we learn
math until 18 we'll like have a better
surrounding of the world so we'll know
if we like need to save like more money
and like if we buy like something we'll
know how much money we have left what do
you think
that's a good point but
um also some some people over 16 may may
disagree with you because they would
want to go through a different career
path that doesn't involve maths I think
this be a choice because people may want
to study other subjects that they are
more interested in letting myself into
the age of 18 is a good idea because it
teaches us how to take care of money pay
bills and make sure we have enough money
for important things in life we should
only have to do math until we're 16
because at this age people may decide to
take different Puffs and pursue other
interests but it's not math a level so
the last thing I'm going to say on this
so everyone watching it doesn't mean
everyone has to do maths a level but
what it does mean is we need to study
some maths up to 18. so why is it that
we have to study maths like I get the
obviously in some cases we do need maths
but surely we can just use our phones
you know we've got calculators on our
phones why is it that we have to know it
in our heads well this is not about
knowing it in your heads but it's about
knowing what calculation to put in your
phone when you do it right it's about
knowing the things that you need to ask
your calculator or your Excel
spreadsheet or you know your AI chat bot
down the line and GPT I have two young
girls right who are a bit younger than
you guys and when they first heard about
me talking about this you know they were
not happy as well right they were also
like you they're like whoa what's all
this about and I've sat down and
explained to them I don't think they're
fully persuaded yet but I'm going to
keep watch this interview and they'll be
a bit more persuaded so with policies
like that about our education this is
another great question from our FYI News
Club member
foreign
party saved they will get into power
they will reduce the voting age to 16.
in Scotland 16 year olds converting
their local elections will you reduce
the voting age so we can all get say
so Louise I think the right thing is to
have a voting age at 18 and I tell you
why 18 is the age that most people think
that you become an adult and it's when
you can do lots of adult things but what
I'd say is voting isn't the only way you
can participate have your voice heard
look at what you guys are doing look at
all your news club members like Louise
are doing they're getting engaged
they're watching they're sending in
questions
how committed are you to saving the
planet from climate change
so I am committed to making sure that we
leave our environment in a much better
state for you guys and everyone watching
I've got two young daughters as I said
right it's really important for me but
if that
your coal miner I don't get it I tell
you why because even the experts even
the independent climate experts all
agree that we are going to need some oil
and gas for a while to come until we
transition to a future which is
completely green where all our energy
comes from Green sources and it's also
good for climate because instead of
asking some other country to produce it
and then shipping it all the way here
with twice the carbon emissions we can
do it at home without doing that so
actually it's a sensible thing to be
doing in the short term right and this
is for the short term as we transition
to Net Zero by 2050 that's the plan and
we're on track to do that so we've got
another question now from the FYI News
Club at St Joseph's Primary School
[Music]
one of your children turns out to be
part of the lgbtq plus Community what
would you do
[Music]
would you support them yeah of course
and as it goes back to what we'll talk
about right at the beginning actually
your first question Maya and it's about
you know not judging anybody and it's
about being understanding about being
compassionate and tolerant of everyone
and the choices they make and making
sure that we can support them you know
we have to be really sensitive with some
of these things when it comes to
children and making sure that we as
adults who are responsible for our
children you know are helping them as
they think about through some of these
things and doing that in a sensitive way
and of course there's quite a big event
coming up soon the coronation oh yes
what are you going to be doing well it's
going to be great first of all are you
guys excited of course yeah exactly so
look I'm really lucky because I you know
my job you know I get to meet um is
actually the king every week and we have
a meeting every week it's called an
audience and I go every week to meet
with the King and have a chat about
what's going on that's your relationship
like do you guys get honor your mates
yeah yeah well I said I have I'd say
well I'm the Prime Minister he's uh he's
the king but I tell you one thing is you
know when I have these conversations
with him and I can see just how
unbelievably committed he is to serving
our country now I'm I'm really excited
about the concert you guys excited about
the concert because that's the best bit
that's the best bit well there's some
other bits I have to do as well I think
I am looking forward to the concert
um because Katy Perry is coming right my
girl's a big fan of Katy Perry so that's
great I think it's going to be it's
going to be a great weekend for the
country we're all just going to
celebrate you know this is a really
special moment France and it's a great
moment for us to come together I think
the world is going to see what a special
place the United Kingdom is and it's
just make us going to make us all really
proud to be British on that day that's
what I think I saw super exciting thank
you so much for your time it's super
busy so it's been wonderful speaking to
you this has been really good I've
really enjoyed it thank you thank you
Braden thank you very much
so we've interviewed the Prime Minister
and the man who wants his job serkiest
armor the leader of the labor party you
can watch both our interviews on our
webpage and why not have a debate at
your school about who would get your
vote to lead our country just head to
first.news forward slash FYI